hiya Georgie hi can you want to go for a
ride alright guys so right after we get
this video up on YouTube we are jetting
over to San Diego Comic Con so tomorrow
that is Friday July 19 I am hosting a
panel for the 8th episode Amazon
exclusive series dark web at the
hoarding Grand Theatre which has just
found out the it chapter 2 panel was
actually just yesterday at that same
theatre lucky me I got a following right
now looking online I see we have over
230 people reserved to already attend
the panel I've never spoken to that many
people at once this is exciting
we're almost at full capacity so if
you're going to San Diego comic-con make
sure to reserve a spot dark web is this
serialized anthology series it follows
this mystery drama about tracking down a
missing person which of course has like
these dark cyber technology elements
infused throughout but each episode also
weaves an anthology tale think of it
like a like a tales from the dark web my
plan was to at least watch like four
episodes just to feel prepared for it
but I ended up binging the whole thing
because guys it's seriously like a
really great show there's some truly
clever writing throughout I absolutely
love every single one of the anthology
stories they're eerie
tense suspenseful character driven
thought-provoking they're all
wonderfully directed very unique to one
another the acting is great no joke I
really recommend it I am so happy I get
to host this panel looks so happy
because the show is actually really good
it premieres tomorrow on Amazon Prime
same day or the panel so make sure to go
check it out online on anyway onto it
chapter 2
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
not be excited if it never comes back
strange things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lazy eyes God I'm loving the feeling of
it it's so much of Pennywise is pissed
he wants to make you suffer because in
that first one he's just so gleeful and
doing what he does alright and this time
it feels like personal for everyone
involved I could already tell I don't
know if it's gonna be better than it
chapter one but it's gonna far exceed
the adult version of the miniseries
that's pretty sure there's not a doubt
in my mind it's gonna be better than
that yeah well it looks like they're
dialing up the intensity for sure
because I thought the first it there the
remake from a couple years ago was
really well done but one thing I could
have maybe used a bit more of was like
suspense and tension and this makes it
look like a really tense really a
fraught movie
yeah and that's exciting to me yeah I
mean well the truths for the the first
movie didn't really capitalize on the
fun interaction that the characters were
gonna be having I think that was a
really fun surprise a lot of us felt
when we were watching the movie I feel
like we'll get that with these guy hope
so every half mile of watching famous
people interact with one another I want
to see you know the chemistry with all
them and I finished all of Bury on HBO
recently I have now joined the Bill
Hader train every time I want to line
someone's raving about Bill Hader and I
was like what's so great about Bill I'm
sure he's a talented guy right now I
watch Barry I'm like oh I see what all
the hype about now I'm super duper
excited that he's in this movie he's
easily the one I'm most looking forward
to see him what he does near there was
like the least capitalized went on James
McAvoy was in this a lot and then yeah
just fantastic remember her frickin name
at the time and it looks like they did
bring back some of the cast from part
one to do like flashback scenes yeah
they said that the younger versions
would be you know somewhat integral to
the story at least so yeah I imagine
those actors are all gonna make
appearances throughout this and like
slightly new footage and stuff right
right I'm sure if I went to the IMDB and
really studied it I can be a hundred
percent about this this might be a
potential spoiler if you have seen the
miniseries or read the book but the guy
in the in the mental hospital I am
assuming that is the bully character
from part one and he's all grown up now
okay I won't go into plot details in
case you happen to skip out on both of
those things either way like the the
funhouse element to it does look very
in-your-face it feels very hard you know
yeah it looks like it's got a good
amount of that surreal stuff as well and
according to Jessica Chastain they used
like a record-breaking amount of blood
on this film so like four thousand five
hundred gallons of fake blood and
there's at least one little shot here
there where she's covered in it so I
gotta imagine they're gonna up the gore
factor here I'm fascinated with because
I remember this commentary was going
around a lot of how stranger things aped
a little bit you know for my Stephen
King and you know things love yeah and
then it seemed to borrow from stranger
things it so it was kind of very much
full circle and then stranger things
season three came out which had this
like big build-up to a fair and a
carnival and a really cool episode that
takes place there and then a lot of this
trailer takes place at a fair even a
mirror maze which I wonder how much of
that is like them nodding to Stephen
King and then this just happening to
coincide in time with that if this is
gonna be one of those unfortunate things
where it's like ha the inspiration and
the proximity to that stuff is kind of
cheapening the effect III don't know
and while I think all the horror and the
gore looks like it's gonna really
deliver on some like excellent thrills
bill scars or looks as great as ever
evidently their budget is bigger you
tell is incredible here my concern is
the the fact that yeah I know you got a
bunch of famous dudes in this movie and
a female in a famous chick
yeah the center of the magazine whatever
that magazine whatever she's the one
woman let her being the center of the
food that's aa bunch of men on there
right everybody in the first movie falls
in love with Beverly at some point yeah
like you've got a continues a little bit
here I do hope that you can still get a
rewarding emotional journey that's not
just on repeat because I didn't read the
book I saw the miniseries and that was
my issue with the adult version it was
boring just seemed to be like hey
remember what are the kids from life
and enemy - cut - the kids together just
so much better yeah and I just don't
want it to be a retread so while I think
they're delivering on the things you
need for like a really cool trailer and
to sell tickets and whatever I I really
do think that what it chapter 1
surprisingly deliver for a worldwide
audience was a great emotional journey
with the characters and you know it's
hard to like convey that and these
trailer so yes hoping that that is also
just as rewarding as it was in part one
I'm hoping it will be I know Andy
machete said that at least for the one
character of Mike they wanted to you
know Isaiah Mustafa who you know he
stays behind he becomes the librarian
and stuff like that and they said they
wanted to make his character have more
of a struggle and more of a trauma
surrounding the events of the first one
and if that is true and if that's the
sensibility they're bringing in I hope
that that will kind of spread to the
other characters and they'll be able to
solve some of the issues that made the
original movie miniseries maybe not so
completely enjoyable huh yeah you know
but either way I'm excited for this I'll
definitely be there comes out three days
after my birthday Oh boom Warner
Brothers getting you for your birthday
you can Warner my birthday contact
Warner Brothers tell them we've already
done four gigs with it can you please
get us on that first for theatrical get
us a new press training as I love to see
this early yeah and then crap all over
your movie yeah no one sees it you know
ruin their Studios a mistake yeah
shouldn't have invited you by you and
then our job is done
yeah I'm more than confident I'm gonna
anyway guys are you excited for in
chapter 2 do you think it will be better
than part 1 make sure to comment below
we got to get going right away
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell we're gonna try to cover whatever
we can if we have time while we're at
Comic Con it's the first time I'm ever
going so I'd like to you know do more
than just stay in a hotel so I'm gonna
be exploring around probably late to
anything that drops and yeah it's gonna
be a Comic Con make sure to check out
the dark web
it starts at 1:30 p.m. and the show dark
web premieres tomorrow
[Music]